على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد
فوصلنا
الى ذكر بدايات الهجره
بدايات الهجره النبويه وذكرنا ان الهجره
هجره النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم كانت في
شهر ربيع
الثاني
وهجره المسلمين كانت بعد بيعه العقبه
الثانيه وهذا كان في الموسم
لذلك عنا التاريخ
والسنه الهجريه تبتدا من محرم
لانه الشهر الذي يلي ذي الحجه محرم وفي
محرم
ابتدا المسلمون
بهجراتهم الى مدينه رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم وهو ابتدا
وشرع فيه تاهيل نفسه
وايضا تاهيب ابي بكر كما سياتي ان شاء
الله تعالى
يقول ابن القيم واذن رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم للمسلمين في الهجره الى المدينه
فبادر الناس
فكان اول من خرج اليها ابو سلمه وامراته
ولكنها حبست عنه سنه وحيل بينها وبين
ولدها ثم خرجت
بعد بولدها الى المدينه وشيعها عثمان بن
ابي طلحه رضي الله عنه
ثم خرج الناس ارسالا ارسالا يعني جماعات
ولم يبقى بمكه الا رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم وابو بكر وعلي
تصوروا هذه
يعني تصوروا هذا الموقف
اشتد
تعذيب
اهل مكه
وصناديق قريش اشتد تعذيبهم للمسلمين
فابداوا
بالخروج وشرعوا في الهجره
ارسالا ارسالا الى المدينه
وفي ثلاث اشهر
كانوا كلهم ذهبوا الى المدينه لم يبقى احد
ما في في كل مكه الا ثلاثه من المسلمين بس
هذا طبعا بعد موت ابي طالب وبعد موت خديجه
وكان هذا امر خطير جدا على النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم وعلى ابي بكر وعلى علي
لكن
ابا بكر وعلي رضي الله عنهما قد ابى ان
يخرج قبل رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
وكان اخر من هاجر
هو علي بن ابي طالب رضي الله عنه خرج بعد
خروج النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم بقليل
يقول ثم خرج الناس ارسالا ولم يبقى بمكه
الا رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم وابو
بكر وعلي
اقام بامره لهما
والا
من احتبسه المشركون
كرها يعني الذي لا يستطيع ان يهاجر لفقره
الذي لا يستطيع ان يهاجر لي
قله ذات اليد او لان المشركين
احاطوا به اما
يكونوا مثلا متزوج من وماخذ بنت حدا من
هؤلاء المشركين فيحبسوا البنت اللي بدك
تاجر روح لحالك خلي بنتنا عنها
مساله صعبه جدا كذلك الاولاد وكذلك حجز
الاموال
كما حصل مع صهيب الرومي رضي الله عنه
عندما جاء ليخرج مهاجرا الى المدينه حبسوه
حبسته قريش كفار قريش وقالوا انت اتيتنا
صعلوقا يعني ما الك مال
اتيتنا صعلوقا
واستفدت عنا كل هذه الاموال ان تجمعتها
بين اظهورنا والان تظن انك تحمل مالك
وتذهب لا
فقال رايتم لو
افتديت نفسي بهذه الاموال كلها
اتركتموني اهاجر قالوا نعم فخلا لهم كل
المال وخرج من مكه
بمثل ما دخل فيها
لكن الله سبحانه وتعالى انزل فيه ومن
الناس من يشري نفسه ابتغاء مرضاه الله
يشري نفسه يعني يبيع نفسه وهو كذلك فعل
فهذه مواقف حصلت مع الصحابه رضي الله عنهم
ومنهم
من اشتد عليه الامر
فتراجع ولم يهاجر ابدا وبقي لضعفه ليس
لعذر شرعي ولكن لضعف
وهذا الضعف كان غير معذور عند الله سبحانه
وتعالى
حتى اشتد الحرب بين النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم واعدائه فقتلوا في صفوف المشركين حصل
هذا في بدر حصل هذا
وكانوا غير معذورين الله عز وجل عذر من
الهجره
الرجال والنساء والولدان الذي لا يستطيعون
حيله ولا يهتدون سبيلا
فانظر الى
الايه يقول الله سبحانه وتعالى
العذر يكون قائما عند الله
للرجال والنساء والولدان الذين لا
يستطيعون حيله
ولا يهتدون سبيلا
قال الله
فاولئك عسى الله ان يعفو عنهم
يعني انظر شده الامر يعني حتى هؤلاء
الله عز وجل جعل لهم العذر لكن يقول
بكلمه عسى ان يعفو عنهم
وهذا طبعا في حق الله سبحانه وتعالى هو
واقعي وهو متيقن لكن هذا الاسلوب يدل على
حتى هؤلاء كادوا الا يكونوا معذورين
انت ما الك انك تجلس بين هؤلاء وتكثر
اموالهم واقتصادهم وتكثر سوادهم على حساب
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم واصحابه واحنا
ذكرنا احكام الهجره والامر بالمهاجره في
دروس سبقت لكن
لا يمكن لنا ان نقيس هذه الهجره التي كانت
واجبه
ومن تركها لم يكن معذورا عند الله سبحانه
وتعالى ممن يستطيع اليها سبيلا
ليست هذه كمثلا نحن الان في امريكا في
دوله غير مسلمه هل يجوز لنا القيام هنا
هذه مساله بتا فيها العلماء
وبحثوها بحثا
قويا وجمهور اهل العلم والحجه معهم ان شاء
الله ان هذه الهجره تكون في اقصى احوالها
مستحبه واما الوجوب فالوجوب فالوجوب يكون
الهجره من بلد لا يستطيع الانسان ان يقيم
دينه فيها بده يخفي دينه
ما بقدر يطرا سيره الصلاه ولا يظهر شيء من
دينه ما يستطيع يذهب الى المسجد ما يستطيع
يقيم الجمعه والجماعات وما يستطيع ان
يصوموا هذه تحصل في بعض
زوايا الارض يعني مثلا في الصين وهي دوله
اشتراكيه وما زالت قويه في الاشتراكيه فهم
يرغمون الناس
على الفطر في رمضان
شيء عجيب سبحان الله يرغمون المسلمين
على الفطر في رمضان لا وقف الشرطي وقف كل
قدامي اشرب هذه الميه غصبا عنك
لكن الله سبحانه وتعالى
يعني كما يستهزئون بدينه الله يستهزئ بهم
ويمدهم لانه هل ممكن تفطر الصائم غصبا عنه
يعني شرعا هل ممكن تفطر الصائم غصبا عنه
الجواب لا
الفطر في الاسم في الاسلام يكون مقرون
بالنيه الفطر الشرعي يعني واحد ارغمته
واكرهته على الاكل والشرب في رمضان وهو
صائم فانه يتم صومه
لكن من مثل هذه البلد لها هذه الاوصاف لا
يجب وجوبا لمن استطاع ان يهاجر ان يهاجر
منها لانه الان ما يستطيع يقيم دينه ومن
اقامه الدين ليس فقط مظاهر الدين مثل
الصلاه والصيام
وبناء المساجد وما شابه ذلك وايضا
الصدع
بقواعد الدين واصول الدين يعني تكون في
بلد
تستطيع تقول الله واحد من عبد غير الله
فانما عبده بالجاهل والظلم والعدوان
ولا اله الا الله وتصدع بهذه الكلمه فاذا
كنت في مكان تستطيع هذه الاشياء
فالمهاجره من مثل هذا المكان اقصى احواله
يكون
مستحب
وفي الدول الاشتراكيه هذه كانت منتشره جدا
يعني في روسيا وفي زمن
دوله الاشتراكيه القويه هذه التي كانت في
الاتحاد السوفيتي
تسمى كان الاسلام والديانات كافه ممنوعه
ممنوعه
ومن كان يتجاسر على قراءه ايه من القران
فانه كان يعذب عذابا اليما ويذوق من
الويلات الشيء المهول
لكن الحمد لله هذا امر يندر ويكثر في
امثال هذه البلدان التي
تحكم بالاشتراكيه والاشتراكيه هذه طامه
كبرى نزلت على البشريه
وجاءت بالبؤس على البشريه بشكل عام فعلى
كل حال
هؤلاء
هاجروا كل من استطاع ان يهاجر هاجر
والسؤال هل كان الواجب
المهاجره من مكه الى اقرب مكان يستطاع فيه
اقامه الدين ام كان الواجب عليهم الهجره
من مكه الى المدينه خاصه
في فرق
والظاهر والله اعلم ان الهجره كانت
واجبه الى مكان يقام فيه الدين لانه حتى
في عامل الوفود
وفود كثيره جاءت ونزلت عند رسول الله صلى
الله عليه وسلم في المدينه يعلمهم ويفتيهم
ويرسل معهم من الصحابه ويعودون الى بلادهم
ولم يكونوا يهاجرون
لكن قد يكون الامر انه في بدايه الهجره
وفي بدايه دوله الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
هذه الهجره كانت واجبه الى المدينه كانت
واجبه الى المدينه
لتكثير سواد المسلمين
ليكون للمسلمين شوكه
قال واعد رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
جهازه ينتظر متى يؤمر
عفوا قال واعد رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم جهازه جهازه يعني
ما يتجهز به من الزاد والدابه وما شابه
ذلك
اعد رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم جهازه
ينتظر متى يؤمر واعد ابو بكر جهازه فلما
راى المشركون اصحاب رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم قد خرجوا
وساقوا الذراري والاموال الى المدينه
وانها دار منعه واهلها اهل باس ما كانوا
ضعفاء الاوس والخزرج واهل يثرب كانوا
جماعه لهم باس شديد في الحرب
خافوا خروج رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
فيشتد عليهم امره
الان
قالوا الكل هاجر الى هذا المكان واحنا
بنعرف الاوس والخزرج واهل المدينه واهل
يثرب هذول جماعه اصحاب عهد ووفاء واصحاب
باس في الحرب شديد
كانهم يقولون هذه اخر فرصه نقطع دابر هذا
الامر انه ما نخلي الرسول يهاجر اليهم
فاذا اجتمع اليهم في دار منعه وباس فان
الحروب ستشتد بيننا ويكون لهم شوكه
فاجتمعوا في دار الندوه
دار الندوه كانت قريبه او
قريبه من ساحه الكعبه كانوا يجتمعون فيها
صناديق قريش ويبثون في الامور
ويتفاخرون بالانساب وما شابه ذلك وفيه من
الشورى ما كان
وحضرهم ابليس في صوره شيخ من اهل نجد
مشتمل الصماء في كسائه فاشاره كل واحد
براي والشيخ لا يرضاه
مشتمل الصماء في كسائه يعني كان دخل عليهم
وتمثل لهم رجلا
وكان مغطي وساتر على حاله
ويدلي بدلوه
والكل يظن الثاني بعرفه يعني دخل في
المجلس انا بنفسي ما اعرف ولكن بجوز صاحبي
هذا يعرفه
على كل حال كل ما
ذكروا رايا
نمنعه نفعل نسوي ولا يرضى يقول لا شوفوا
حل ثاني
الحال هذا الحل ما بوفي وهو ابليس ماذا
يريد
يريد ان يؤزهم على قتله ولا يرضى باقل من
ذلك
وقال الله سبحانه وتعالى في هذا واذ يمكر
بك الذين كفروا ليثبتوك او يقتلوك او
يخرجوك
فالذي
يريدونه ان يثبتوه ايش يعني يثبتوه يعني
يجعلونه يفتتن عن دينه
ويداهم معهم
وتكون دعوته ليست قويه فيثبت فاذا ما
استطاعوا الى ذلك فالقتل احسن
واذا ما استطاعوا ذلك اقل الاحوال ان
يخرجوا
فابليس اراد بهذا ان
يشد من عزمهم في قتل الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم
قال
فاشار كل واحد براي والشيخ لا يرضى هذا
الشيخ النكره لا يرضاه حتى قال ابو جهل
ارى ان ناخذ من كل قبيله غلاما جلده
فارس يعني
ثم نعطيه سيفا صارما
ثم يضربونه ضربه رجل واحد
فلا تدري بنو عبد مناف ما تصنع بعد ذلك
ونسوق ديته
يعني لو كانت من قبيله واحده
ممكن
يحاربوا هذه القبيله
لكن لو اجتمعت القبائل
وانتخبوا غلاما فارسا من كل قبيله وضربوا
ضربه الرجل الواحد يتفرق دم الرسول صلى
الله عليه وسلم بان كل القبائل الان ما
يستطيع
ما تستطيع بن عبدي مناف ان يطالبوا وان
يقاتلوا جميع القبائل فنسوق الديه يعني
الديه بتكون غصبا عنهم هذيك الساعه
قال الشيخ هذا والله الراي
فتفرقوا عليه
فجاءه جبريل فاخبره وامره الا ينام في
مضجعه تلك الليله
وجاء رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم الى
ابي بكر نصف النهار في ساعه لم يكن ياتيه
فيها متقنعا
مغطي على وجهه ساتر فقال له اخرج من عندك
فقال انما هم اهلك يا رسول الله
الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم خايف حتى يحكي
قدام اي واحد هذا شيء بينه وبين ابو بكر
والواحد ما كان يستطيعي امن لاي احد
فقال له اخرج من عندك يعني بدي احكي معك
فقال انما هم اهلك يا رسول الله فقال ان
الله قد اذن لي في الخروج
فقال ابو بكر الصحبه يا رسول الله قال نعم
قال فخذ بابي وامي احدى راحلتي هاتين فقال
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم بالثمن
طبعا ابو بكر ما بده طالبه لا بثمن ولا
بشيء لكن الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
كان كريما وكان يابى
ياخذ من احد الا ما كانت منهم هديه
يبتدئونه بها
والا
وهذا يحصل يعني ممكن
ممكن واحد
تقول له والله هذه ساعه حلوه او شيء
يقول هذه لك يعني خذها
يعني ليس من الجميل ان يستعمل ومن المروءه
انه
صاحب الجاه
يستعمل جاهه للاشياء الصغيره او الاشياء
التافهه الجاه يصرف فيه مرضاه الله سبحانه
وتعالى ليس في اكتساب
الاشياء الدنياويه
فالرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم هو ابتدا
بالطلب لو كانت هديه كان ايش كان ما ذكرها
الهديه جيته حتى فيه في حجرته في في عند
ابي هو وامه لكن هي ليست هديه هو طلب فلما
طلب
عرض عليه
الا ان يكون بغير ثمن خذ احدى راحلتي
هاتين فقال بالثمن
فمن المروءه انه قال بالثمن ومن المروءه
ان قبل ابو بكر رضي الله عنه
وانا احكي هذا ليش لانه احيانا يقع الحرج
الحرج يعني مثلا
خلينا نقول الشيخ
او المفتي او الكبير او صاحب الجاه في
البلد
يحتاج الى اشياء في هالبلد زي باقي الناس
محتاج سيارته يصلحها يحتاج
يروح على الدكاكين يروح على البقالات هيك
فاذا كان كل ما راحه لمكان
قالوا له لا علينا
شيء طيب وجميل لكن اذا انا كل ما جيت عليك
وعلينا جزاك الله خير ماشي المره الجايه
لما يجي عليك كيف بده يكون الجو
الحين يساء الظن فيه كل هذا طمع
صح
وايضا قد يساء الظن بصاحب المحل
ويستغل احدهما الاخر والمساله مش حلوه
الاصل انا بكسب وانت تكسب يا عمي احنا
بنضال اخوان وكل شيء لكن بالثمن
ما تستعصي عليه وتحس انه رد هديتك لا في
فرق بين الهديه وبين المسامحه في شيء هو
طلبه
وهذا ليس من عدم المروءه وليس هذا من عدم
الكرم ان واحد صاحب جاه بيجي عندك على
المحل عندك وانت تعرض عليه مجامل
والمجاملات طيبه
وتقول له وخليها علينا ويصر ان يدفع مرات
بعض الناس بزعل
ليش ما تخليها علينا وخذ في باله لا لاني
لما برجع عليك بكره وبعده
الامور بتصير ايش لككه الامور بتصير محرجه
فهذه مساله
منتشره بين الناس وبيجي من وراها مصايب
عرفت كيف
في فرق بين صاحب
صاحب الهديه او قابل الهديه وهذه المساله
في فرق بينهما
فعلى كل حال
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم قال له ابو بكر
قال فخذ بابي وامي احدى راحلتي هاتين فقال
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم بالثمن
وامر عليا ان يبيت في مضجعه تلك الليله
واجتمع اولئك النفر يتطلعون من صير الباب
يريدون بياته البيات يعني الهجوم ليلا
وياتمرون ايهم يكون اشقاها
يعني هم متسابقين على هذا الشر
والله عز وجل سمى الذي يضرب الضرب القاتله
او الضربه العظمى يسميه في القران اشقى
القوم
والله عز وجل
يقول
فانبعث اشقاهم فانبعث اشقاها يعني اشقى
هذه القبيله اشقاها والذي قام نائبا عن
جميع قومه وهو الذي تمثل فيه رائي قومه
وضرب الضربه
العاقره فعلى كل حال
هو يقول
وياتمرون ايهم يكون اشقاها فخرج رسول الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم فاخذ حفنه من البطحاء
شيء من الرمل فجعل
يذره على رؤوسهم هو على السطح هم نازل
ينظرون في الباب وشايفين اللي بيظنوه
الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
شايفينو في المضجع مضجعه وينظرون من
الفتحات اللي بتكون في الباب طبعا الابواب
في هذاك الزمن اللي بسكن في الدور القديمه
عندنا مثلا في البلاد تذكر ان الدار ايش
هي عباره عن غرفه
وعليه باب من حديد وهذا الحديد بيكون في
فرج بينه وبين الحائط والمقصود منه
الستر العام
وكذلك المقصود منه
مانع
اللصوص وهكذا فهم ينظرون شايفين علي بن
ابي طالب رضي الله عنه في المضجع في مضجع
النبي
ويظنونه النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
والرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم على السطح
ينظر اليهم
فاخذ شيئا من البطحاء
وذره على رؤوسهم من فوق
وهو يتلو وجعلنا من بين ايديهم سدا ومن
خلفهم سدا
فاغشيناهم فهم لا يبصرون من سوره ياسين
فالسؤال ياتي هل هذا عام في جميع الناس
يعني اذا بدي جماعه ما تشوفني اخذ شويه
تراب
واذر هذا التراب على رؤوسهم وعتل هذه
الايه الجواب له
هذه من المسائل التي كانت خاصه بالنبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم
وليس عندنا شيء من عن الصحابه والتابعين
انهم كانوا يفعلون ذلك
فعلى كل حال هذه من ايات
وايات النبوه للنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
وهي خاصه به
ومضى الى بيت ابي بكر
فخرج من خوخه فيه ليلى وجاء رجل فراى
القوم ببابه
فقال ما تنتظرون
قالوا محمدا
قال خبتم وخسرتم قد والله مر بكم
وذر على
رؤوسكم التراب
يعني واحد في الحاره شايف القصه كلها
والرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم لما تلا هذه
الايه وذر هذا التراب على رؤوسهم طبعا
البيت مالوش الا طريق واحد ينزل عنه نزل
عن هذا الطريق من امامهم ومر من امامهم
ولم يروا
وهذا من
من
اياته صلى الله عليه وسلم
فقاموا ينفضون عن رؤوسهم فلما اصبحوا قام
علي عن الفراش فسالوه عن النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم فقال لا علم لي به
ما ادري
وممكن يكون هذا الكلام صحيح انه ما يدري
الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم اذا اراد ان
يخرج
فالافضل والامن له
ولعلي الا يخبره بطريقه
ولا باتجاه
فعلي رضي الله عنه الذي عرفه كان غلاما
يعني شابا في ذاك الوقت خلى علي بن ابي
طالب رضي الله عنه وراءه في مكه عشان عنده
امانات للقوم
هذول كفار ومشركين وعذبوه وعذبوا
اهل وعذبوا وعذبوا المسلمين وفعلوا ما
فعلوا
لكن هذا ما له دخل في ايش في الامانه
لذلك جاء في الحديث الحديث فيه ضعف معناه
صحيح ولا تخن من خانك
ولا تخن من خانك خيانه فلان ما بتبرر
خيانتك ابدا
وهذا يقع كثيرا وبعض الناس يحتج بفعله
يحتج
بفعل فلان على تبرير فعله وتبرير ساحته
هذا يحصل وهذه من
عقليات التي تكون عند الكفار تفعل بالثاني
كالذي يفعل بك اذا هو
خاني فانا بخونه وهذا ابدا ما يكون في
الاسلام
الخيانه هي الخداع في موضع في موضع الامن
ايش يعني هذا الكلام يعني هل يوصف الله عز
وجل
بالخيانه لا هل ينسب اليه فعل الخيانه لا
ابدا
قال الله تعالى وان يريدوا خيانتك فقد
خانوا الله من قبل فامكن منهم
ما قال فخانهم
لكن في الخداع قال يخادعون الله وهو
خادعهم ما فيها شيء
يستهزئون الله يستهزئ بهم
لان الاستهزاء في موضعه من الكمال
الاستهزاء بالمستهزئ من الكمال
وكذلك
مخادعه
الخادع من العدو فهذا من الكمال لكن
الخيانه ابدا ما تكون من الكمال هذا نقص
بحث
ما هو ما هي الخيانه الخيانه تعريفها كما
ذكرنا
هو
الخداع في
موضع الامن
تعطي واحد الامان وبعدين بتغدر هذا هو
الغدر هذه الخيانه وهذه ابدا ما تكون في
الدين لا من مؤمن ابدا
وانما يكون
الخدع الحرب خدعه او خدعه ما فيها شيء
والتوريه ما فيها شيء هذا يكون في الحرب
وفي الضرورات لكن الخيانه مسلم لا يكون
خائنا
فعلى كل حال
هم خان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
خانوه في امور كثيره ونقضوا العهد
واساؤوا اليه واعتدوا عليه
لكن هذا كله لم يدفعه الى خيانتهم حتى في
الاشياء الايش البسيطه الامور الدنيويه
هذا خلى عنده ذهب وهذا خلى عنده شويه مال
هذا خلى عنده شيء
فكانوا ياتون بهذه الامانات
ويرغبون
بامانته عن امانه اقاربهم والعرب كانت في
ذاك الزمن كانوا يفتخرون بالامانه ما كان
في مثل هذا الزمان هذا الزمان الان
يعني لا تجد الامين الا نادرا نادرا وكما
وصف النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ان الامانه
ترفع من قلوب الناس ويكون الامر حتى يقال
ان في بني فلان رجلا امينا
يعني خلاف العاده الاصل
انه الخائن هو الذي ينتشر سمعته بين الناس
والا في الاصل للناس في عندهم امانه لكن
في بني فلان عندهم رجل خائن اياك منه لكن
في اخر الزمان في مثل هذا الزمان العكس
الخيانه هي الاصل والامانه هذه هي الطاره
المستثنى من الاصل ايش الامانه والعياذ
بالله والعفه
والشهامه
والشجاعه والكرم هذه اشياء اصبحت ماذا
طارئه على الناس ليست اصلا
فاذا الناس انتزعوا من الدين عادوا الى
عادوا الى احوال الانسان قبل
ان تشرق عليه شمس الرساله وشمس الوحي
عقل الانسان قبل ذلك يكون ماذا
يكون مليئا بالوساوس والاوهام
والنزعه الى الاصول
اصول الانسان يعني من
الظلم والجهل هذه الاشياء التي وصف الله
سبحانه وتعالى بها الانسان الانسان في
اصله هيك هذه الاشياء مغروزه فيه
فعلى كل حال
الامانه
كانت في وقت الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
يفتخر بها بين العرب ويتفاخرون ويتنافسون
في الامانه
وينشدونا عن في الامانه اشعارا
لكن مع كل هذا كان الغريب منهم
ياتي النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
ويضع امانته عنده
ويراه اولى من
اهله واقاربه
وهم يؤذونه ويعلم ان امانتي عنده
لكن يؤذونه
ويسبونه ويظلمون
ويعرفون مع كل ذلك امانتهم غير ضائعه ما
في حدا اجاوكل ما دام ان الامر هيك اعطيني
امانتي مش مامنك لا
لذلك كان هو المعروف المنتشر بين
الناس من سمعته انه كان ايش كان الامين
معروف بالامين
وهذه ايضا من دلائل النبوه يعني كيف يترك
الكذب على الناس
ويلوذ على الكذب على رب العالمين سبحانه
وتعالى هذا كيف يعني يكون
يستعظم ان يكذب على الناس لكن لا يستعظم
ان يكذب على الله ويقول اوحي الي ولم يوحى
اليه شيء هذا غير معقول
فعلى كل حال
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم خلى علي بن ابي
طالب ورى عشان يؤدي لكل واحد امانته يعني
الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم صار خارج هاجر
ليس من اهل البلد الان وهذه اماناتكم
تفضلوا
قال ابن القيم رحمه الله ثم مضى وابو بكر
الى غار ثور فدخل
كلام شوي غريب يعني
التركيب ثم مضى وابو بكر
يعني الواو هنا واو
واو مصاحبه يعني مع ابو بكر
او العطف يكون على ضمير مستتر ثم مضى يعني
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ومعه ابو بكر
الى غار ثور فدخله
وضرب العنكبوت على بابه وكان قد استاجرا
ابن ابن اوريقط الليثي وكان ماهرا بالطريق
وهو على دين قومه
قصه العنكبوت التي ضربت
ببيتها على باب
الغار قصه مذكوره متداوله عند اهل السير
والاصل ان هذه السيره اكثرها ماخوذه من
سيره ابن هشام سيره ابن هشام ماخوذه
من دون اسانيد وازمه الى من سيره ابن
اسحاق اوسع السير وهي سيره مفقوده للاسف
فطاعت كثير من الاسانيد
هذه
رد كثير من اهل العلم
ممن لهم نفس
اثري ردوا هذه القصه قصه العنكبوت وقصه
ايش قصه الحمامه
يعني انه جلس في غار ثور فالعنكبوت اجى
وكان بيت العنكبوت على باب الغار وايضا
الحمامه اجت وحطت البيضات على الباب
فلما اتوا على هذا الغار نظروا فقالوا لو
دخل كان اخترق هذا البيت بيت العنكبوت
وكان هذه الحمامه يعني هربت لكن
هذه القصه لا باس ذكرها بعض الناس يشدد في
هذه المساله احيانا
وينبغي ان نعرف انها مساله ممكنه اليس
كذلك ممكن ليس ممتنعا
وذكرها بعض العلماء وبعض التابعين ذكروا
هذه القصه
فالعلماء يستانسون بهذه لان الاصل لان
الله تعالى يعمل باسباب يقدر اسبابا
سبحانه وتعالى وهذه من الاسباب
وان كان الاصل اذا كان الله حجب عن عيونهم
ان يروا رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
وابا بكر
انما امره اذا اراد شيئا ان يقول له كن
فيكون لكن في العاده
الامور التي يقول الله فيها كن فتكون
فتكون بالاسباب
يخلق لها اسبابا سبحانه وتعالى فهذه قصه
العنكبوت وقصه الحمامه ممكنه ذكرها كثير
من العلماء وليس ثم شيء يمنع
ويستانس بها لان المقام ايش مقام اوسع من
ذكر
الروايه عن رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
في فرق في فرق وهذه مساله كثير من الطلاب
ما يعقلون هذه المساله وذلك ان
شده النظر في صحه الاسناد يختلف على حسب
من يكون الاسناد
منتهيا اليه اذا كان الاسناد ينتهي الى في
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم لا بنشدد
وبندور على اي عله
واذا كان الى
ابي بكر وعمر فلهما سنه سنه الخلفاء
الراشدين نشدد لكن دون
التشدد الذي كان فيه
طلب هذه الصحه من
الاسناد الذي يؤدي الى كلام الرسول صلى
الله عليه وسلم واذا كان عن الصحابه
فتكون الامور اوسع واذا كان في مسائل لا
ينبني عليها احكاما بتكون اوسع واوسع لان
الاصل لان الاخبار لها اصل
الى انما تورد لانها قيلت
على كل حال هي مساله واسعه ما فيها حرج
وان شاء الله تعالى سياتي علينا امثال هذه
الاقوال والروايات المنتشره في كتب السير
ناتي عليها ان شاء الله
ونكتفي بهذا القدر والله اعلم وصلى الله
وسلم على نبينا محمد
الله اكبر الله اكبر